[Musique]
eh bien je voudrais simplement vous
demander de bien vouloir nous excuser il
n'y aura évidemment aucune émission avec
des chansons à l'heure de ce rendez vous
qui êtes habituellement gay puisque vous
savez que nous sommes tous frappés aux
buttes-chaumont d'une souris une famille
claude françois
d'ailleurs à côté de moi j'ai nous
sommes sans voix il ya michel drucker
qu'il l'attendait ainsi que sylvie et
pierre perret est à mes côtés enfin nous
sommes complètement perdus qu'ils
veulent la voir dans l'émission la wii
on attendait 108 à mesure est déjà là il
avait fait téléphoner qu'il arrive et
qui reposeront donc tu connais en pis
pour tous sachent qu'on n'était pas bien
réalisé encore ils sont français
non je crois que c'est ça paraît
impossible qu'un club françois que fait
partie de tout ce que nous avons connu
de tous que nous on s'assure que s'est
investie à l'excédent bête d'ailleurs le
flash tout à l'heure de patrick lecocq
nous apprend dès que c'est en manipulant
une lampe électrique et s'est
électrocuté
parce que si les je suis aussi
complètement anéanti je crois que tous
ceux qui sont là réagissent de la même
façon et qu'on est bouleversé par cette
nouvelle a tracé 6e mais les gars de
l'indécente à côté ils ont même pas ils
sont sans raison même pas voulu venir
je veux dire que là il ya plus donné de
1ère 2ème chaîne nous sommes tous réunis
parce que finalement la grande famille
des variétés ses déboires toujours cru
que nous prononçons dans ces moments là
est frappé de stupeur dans l'accident
bête comme me disait marie picard band
il ya 2 minutes et d un accident de
voiture c'est presque - berck de
s'électrocuter dans sa salle de bain
enfin bref
comment 10 dans ces cas là la phrase
rituelle le spectacle continue en tout
cas demain nous allons dès qui est notre
édition accueille j'imagine oui moi je
pense que je vais en faire autant la
semaine prochaine et est que le coeur de
tous les tous et ses grands amis vont
battre pendant que je voudrais
m'adresser une somme que vous connaissez
tous qui est la maman de clown et pour
lui dire que nous partageons son chagrin
et sa détresse côté voit la situation et
la voyez les caméras on sent même
baisser a plu à plus de possibilité pour
tous de faire la moindre émission de
variétés effectivement demain tout le
monde se sera ressaisie parce que
finalement il a raison notre ami michel
la fête continue en fait les variétés
continue demain il va consacrer une
émission à claude
moi j'en frottant la semaine prochaine
le soir notre ami pierre perret qui
devait terminer cette émission
personnellement je n'y vois pas
d'inconvénient guy je devais encore
chanter quelques chansons je préfère je
peux pas tellement aujourd'hui voilà bon
je veux dire que c'est pas la peine en
tous cas nous ajouterions serait
parfaitement inutile il nous manque
quelque chose désormais il nous manquera
encore très longtemps quelque chose sur
nos plateaux il ya quelques instants
michel arrêt c'est un mois la maman moi
je connaissais aussi klaus avait des
liens profonds d'amitié tous ses amis
doivent être terrassé ans non comme nous
le sommes nous donnant une image un peu
triste nous sommes pas préparés à ce
genre de coup finalement on n'attendait
pas ça bon et bien voilà on revend
l'antenne nos actualités
il est un fait qu'il est assez difficile
et d'enchaîner comme ça mais comme le
disait michel drucker le spectacle
continuer notre programme seront n 2
continue bien sûr